So, welcome to the show, guys. I'm
excited to talk about this topic here
because I think that we need some help
in the sexual purity area and you guys
are heralding this direction. Tell us a
little bit about your ministry. Would
you like to start, Mike? Sure. So,
Coming Together Ministries was started
actually 14 years ago as Coming Out
Ministries. And there were five
individuals that had all come out of the
LGBT lives. And when we met each other,
we were absolutely shocked that somebody
else could come out of the gay culture
into Christianity. And as we got
together and we started to share our
stories, um each one of us realized that
we needed resources when we were young
and we walked out of the church when we
were about 20 and we wanted to provide
the resources that we were desperate for
as we were you know in that journey. Um
actually I I think it would be good to
give a little bit of our background if
we could. But um as the ministry moved
on uh people left, people came in. Uh
the ministry has has changed a lot. But
one thing that was really clear early on
is people would come up to us and they
would hear our testimonies and they go,
"Uh I was never gay, but you know, I
really relate to everything that you
said and we're like, really?" Because
you know in in Christianity
homosexuality was something other than
anything else and there was such a
stigma to it and you know so anybody gay
couldn't be like anybody else and we
were ostracized and marginalized you
know to the point where we just thought
that we must be different too. So coming
into church culture and then having
people say that they related to
everything that we said we started to
realize that um our message is simply
victory over sin. Amen. you know, and
then what that definition of sin really
is, I think, is the big debate, you
know, that's out today. So, as it's the
same for everybody, though. Each every
one of us has something that we're
struggling with. I mean, honestly, if
you don't struggle with um, you know,
LGBT issues, I'm sure as a straight
person, you've been tempted in those
areas as well. So, it's not just like
one or the other. It's all we're all in
this boat. Well, it's interesting
because now culture has defined it to
where there's no there's no borders or
boundaries anymore. It's like gay isn't
being ostracized, is being celebrated.
So, you know, um anyone that came out in
the 1980s like I did, you know, we were
ostracized and, you know, really
ridiculed and and picked on. Whereas
now, if you come out, you're celebrated.
So, I really kind of missed my timing on
that because I I left the gay culture
just as it was coming into vogue. Um but
again when you look at 1 Corinthians
chapter 6 and it talks in 9 and 10 about
all the abominations this horrible word
that you know that are really trigger
words for for many people um with my
history and whatever is it's listing all
of these different sexual issues not
just homosexuality but I really re
resent the church for many years ago I
maybe even a hundred or a thousand years
ago is that they really place
homosexuality
in a separate category all of its own.
It separated it out of that those two
verses when really it talks about
pornography, addiction, lusting, you
know, adultery, you know, uh sex outside
of marriage. It's all included in there.
But for some reason, they ostracized the
homosexual and made this thing that
there was just no redeeming people like
that. And the church bought it, you
know, for many centuries. I guess
everybody else is struggling with their
own issues. So, it's easy to hide behind
the minority sexually and just say, "Oh,
yeah, they're just terrible, but they
had their own skeletons in the closet."
Right. Right. We're not as bad as them.
You know, at least you could put them on
this, you know, in this category. Well,
at least I'm not like them. And I
literally heard that from pastors and
and people in the church, which actually
was the reason why I left when I was 20
years old. Um, so again, our ministry
was designed to provide those resources
and then realizing that we weren't any
different than anybody else was rock,
you know, was like life-changing for us.
And so we we really changed the name to
Coming Together Ministries because I
love verse 11 in uh 2 Corinthians, I'm
sorry, is it first Corinth? It's 1
Corinthians chapter 6 verse 11. It says,
"Such were some of you, but you've been
washed. You've been justified. You've
been sanctified by the Lord Jesus Christ
and by the spirit of our God. So when I
look at that, you know, we don't want to
separate anybody out of that group,
whether God loves them or hates them.
The bottom line is is that you can
change. Not on your own. I could never
change. Could you change, Daniel? Never.
Okay. And temptation isn't sin either.
Right. Right. Which is a really good
point to definitely elaborate on. But in
verse 11 it says Jesus is the one that
justifies and sanctifies us not only by
the death but his resurrection and
through the Holy Spirit. So those are
things that are are accessible to every
person that's in verses 9 and 10. So now
we can put it back in the pot with
everything else and we're all looking
for sexual integrity. So we're all
coming together. So now everybody gets a
t-shirt. I got my t-shirt. Where's my
t-shirt? You're going to get one. You're
going to get one. We're going to make
sure that you get one. But tell me,
Kirsten and Daniel, like you guys are
newly weds. Yes, we are as of May 2024.
Praise God. Congratulations. Thank you.
That's the glow on the face still. I
see. Hopefully, it will stay.
But, you know, you're joining up here
with Michael and you're expanding your
borders a little bit, expanding your
reach on on on on who you're necessarily
targeting. So, um, welcome aboard, guys.
Yes, it's a blessing to be with the
ministry. For those of you who don't
know, um my wife and I before joining
ministry, we were working as social work
therapists. So, we had the call on our
hearts to serve others, to help, to love
on them, and to support them. So, before
joining, that's what we were doing. And
we both have had our own struggles, you
know, with sexual sin and feeling
convicted of those things with our
identity, with our purpose. And it's
been a journey of transformation. And we
just want others to feel and experience
the same thing. Amen. Amen. I love it
that it's like, you know, those those
commercials like I'm not only uh someone
who believes in this product, but I also
use it. You know, it's like I'm a
member. We're
all we're all in this boat together. And
it's time that we just like let the cat
out of the bag and just be like, "Come
on. We got to talk about this because I
really believe that God is trying to do
something special with this group of
people in this end of time." I agree.
Amen. It's very relevant. I'm reminded
of um in the Bible in the story before
the Israelites entered to the promised
land they fell into sexual sin. So I see
that as a parallel to the end of time
before Jesus comes again a lot of his
people are struggling and will fall into
sexual sin because they haven't
surrendered their lives to God in spirit
and in truth meaning truly genuinely
asking God to help them. So I I agree
you know it is a relevant message. It is
sobering but it is hopeful as well.
Yeah, you bring up a really good point
because that story that you're referring
to is the children of Israel right
before they go into the land, the
promised land. They're on the banks,
Moses, everybody else is trying to, you
know, figure out how they're going to go
across and and planning their occupation
of the land of Canaan here. And it's
like that's when they enlisted the
Midianite kings, Balum, like come curse
these people cuz we've heard that their
god's going to give them this land. And
it's like there Balam was like, "Sorry,
nothing you can do to these people. But
if you get them in the sexual realm,
invite them to your parties, let them
just watch how you guys have your
festivities, then they will fall prey to
that idolatrous worship and and sexual
sin and you can have your way with
them." And that's exactly what happened.
And you can cut them off from the
promised land. And that's what's
happening to many many many many of our
churches today. I mean, with the access
of entertainment, access of things to
kids, you know, they they just have
access to nudity like we've never seen
on this planet before. Mhm. Doesn't it
doesn't it also, I think, um, point to
the power of sex, of what sex does? You
know, it's not it it's been this taboo
topic that nobody wants to talk about in
church, but you know what? If we don't
talk about it somehow, even if it's in a
biblical setting, then the world is
educating our young people. And
unfortunately, it's happening younger
and younger and younger all the time.
And I want to add to that same point
because it's like sexuality is something
like unique for us humans because, you
know, God created us in his image and
like we can like reproduce. We c we have
that power through God and the enemy
knows that and he wants to destroy
whether you are destroying your body
itself or you're destroying with someone
else and that's his goal. Yep. I would
say the ultimate in that destruction is
the destruction of the image of God
that's been placed in each one of us. I
think that's really the focus and we
just happen to be attached to that gift
that God gave us. And the devil's like,
"Oh, I'm going to destroy and distort
this image of God that's been placed in
every male and female because he wants
to be like God and he and he can't be
like God." And the fact that we get to
reflect him in a unique way like you
were describing, he hates it. He hates
because he hates God. So there's a lot
of confusion in the world as we all as
we all know. And so our ministry does
strive to bring people back to the image
of God and we have different services
and resources that we want to help
people through. Would you like to talk
about the support groups and the prayer
lines as an easy way for people to get
plugged in? Yes. So I am the nurturing
and mentorship program coordinator. And
basically one of the um projects or
something that I see is the prayer lines
which it's a place where you know
lifting each other up words of
encouragement and there's two types. We
have like a general one and it's for
parents or um just anyone that feels
they want to pray for someone that's
well initially it's you know for those
who um are in the lifestyle LGBTQ
lifestyle but we want to now encompass
like just anyone that needs prayer
requests. Um, so if it's they know
someone who's struggling with porn or if
there's a couple that's going through
infidelity, so we want to just continue
nurturing that as well. And then we also
have an a a support group that it's for
formers and for the formers is for those
who have left the LGBTQ lifestyle and
they have a place to speak to to just
connect with and also uplift each other
up and we want to cons continue just
building that bond with one another and
journeying together with with God as
well cuz we we pray, we play
um and yes, we want to have that safe
environment for them. You know what was
really um interesting to me is that when
Daniel and Kirsten came on board as um
you know members of our team uh you know
we'd been doing the prayer lines for
several years about 10 years and you
know was like praying and scripture
reading and that kind of stuff but you
guys came in and you started playing
games like you were doing this kind of
question and answer thing and it was so
powerful because it not only was
providing support it was also creating
community because now people that
wouldn't uh participate before like all
of a sudden they're jumping in and now
they even say, you know, when you have
the meeting like when are we going to
have game night again? When are we going
to have So you can see what's really
wonderful is you bring in skills that
you have as mast's level social workers.
And what you do is you these games
definitely have a goal in mind. It's not
just loose time, but it actually helps
to bring the team together and creates
community because when you walk away
from sex addiction and porn addiction
and and LGBT issues or whatever, you get
dropped by communities or you've
changed, you know, your um you have to
change a lot of your environmental
factors. So, what I love is that the
prayer lines create that community where
people want to come and to participate.
And yeah, it's been amazing the changes
that you've brought. The devil likes to
isolate you. And um you know when you
guys are building something that is like
you know encouraging people to to you
know come to a safe space um let us love
on you, let us helping walk through this
experience with you and and you guys
have either some personal experiences or
you just some information to help
somebody through that. That's a nice
that's a beautiful opportunity because
you know in the beginning it's like you
you don't know does it does does nobody
want me around you know does do I do I
know does nobody understand me or what
I'm going through and stuff like that
and so um I think that's neat that you
guys are really offering this kind of a
component and isn't that a basic
question where do I belong where do I
fit in and you know it wasn't until many
years after I walked out of the gay
culture that I realized that that this
was the culture that I belonged in all
the time because, you know, before I
went into the gay culture, I certainly
didn't fit in. I was transgender until I
was 20. I felt like I was in the wrong
sex because I felt inadequate as a male.
And then going into the gay culture,
then there was another hierarchy. It's
like, well, if you were bald and short
and not very good-looking or if you
didn't drive the right car or wear the
right label. So, you were always trying
to fit in. And so that question was
always relevant like where do I fit in?
Where do I belong? And you know, it
wasn't until I came back to Jesus
Christ. Now I found my family. I found
that community. I found that body where
it's like, oh, I was meant to be here
all the time. And those questions aren't
just for people that have left LGBTQ
community. I also um left homosexuality
as well. And I had the same questions.
Who am I? You know, why do I have these
temptations, these feelings? the world
is telling me, well, this that's because
that's who you are. So, I'm thinking,
okay, well, let me try this out. So,
when I went to college, that's when I
decided to live that out and was exposed
to the gay culture, which previously I
was mainly doing things online. You
know, we're at
le, you know, I was exposed to a lot of
things online. I was basically, you
know, sexing at a very young age, maybe
middle school, with other adult men and
doing these things that are technically
illegal, which was, you know, making me
more and more um integrated into this
sexual lifestyle, per se. Not just
because I was had this inclination of
homosexuality, but it's the pleasure
seeking that I was going after. It felt
good. It felt nice. And I didn't know
who I was. at my parents, they were
basically like nominal Christians. They
weren't really real genuine Christians
that were reading the word of God, were
having prayer and were doing it
together. So, I didn't find out about
God's power and his love for me
genuinely until after while I was in
college really is where I really had a
real conversion. And um so that's a
little bit about me. And Kirsten, you
also had questions about your identity
as well. Yeah. So the same point of like
whether it's pornography, masturbation,
fornication is the part where like we're
making these decisions and it could be
from a root of many things from like
childhood trauma,
abuse or you know just other topics. So,
I can relate to where I didn't identify
in the LGBTQ lifestyle, but I did fall
into and compromise my sexual integrity
and that I did experience like the
consequences of that, which was I um was
in a
8-year relationships with with two men.
So that's like a chunk of my life of not
knowing who I was cuz my identity was in
romantic relationships and I didn't have
my values either. Um I but I did know
like well growing up it would be like
you know you can't have sexual intimacy
until marriage. And I guess like for
women it's like the emphasis on like
your body. It's you have to wait cuz if
you don't then you're like no good or
just damaged good. So um but I
experienced the same thing too where
once I did ex have those experiences. I
did I was struggling you know and I was
depressed. I was anxious. I was in like
this tri like love triangle inshment and
I was suicidal and the two other guys
that I was um engaging with we were also
suicidal too. So like the consequences
of like when you compromise your sexual
integrity is can be severe. Yes. And
then in this world what I hear a lot is
well maybe you just needed to find the
right partner and maybe you needed just
to have the right boundaries and
consensual sex. But when you attach with
somebody and then you break up with them
that does something to you
psychologically and emotionally. Yes. We
talked a little bit more about the
oxytocin and the attachment that can
happen. Right. Right. What is it?
Oxytocin and the um um there's another
drug that's released in your brain when
you have sex. Yeah. The dopamine and the
oxytocin. Right. So what you find is you
you find this addiction to that because
you really lack the intimacy that you
that we're desperate for. I believe
first of all from our creator and then
our redeemer. But it's interesting
because the three of us also have
something in common even though we're
all uniquely different. Um is that we
had very difficult relationships with
our fathers. Isn't that interesting? And
and what I found in this ministry in the
last 14 years is we're not putting blame
on parents and that kind of thing. But
but we do find that there is a huge huge
amount of people that really struggle at
a very early age. And so I thought that
I was born transgender when really there
was um this rejection that had happened
to my same-sex parent even before I was
conscious. So, you know, I know that
you've had your struggles and and you
came from a single parent home and your
dad wasn't in the home, but it's
interesting when you look back to see
how all of that had an influence. Now we
live in a society where there are more
single mothers raising, you know,
families than dual parents. And so the
father is left behind. He's been
marginalized and basically cut out of
the picture. And you can imagine that
the kind of world that it's creating.
All right, I can do
this. All
[Music]
right. There are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things. Um, never
mind. A way that gets the message out
with confidence.
Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean? Oh,
thank you. You know, we're all made with
a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork. Wow. Where'd you get it?
Lightwear. Wear your witness.
[Music]
You know, it's like uh kind of having
that component as well um to your
ministry. I don't know if you have
something that reaches out to the dads
and you know kind of connects that
bridge like here's here's some examples
of some people that have had horrible
you know father son fatherdaughter
experiences and and how do how do how
how do you as a father I mean I'm a
father so I'm listening to that first
thing I'm thinking is like okay how am I
going to bolster up my relationship with
my kids so that my kids can not have the
you know opportunities maybe being
vulnerable. Yeah. To the things that are
alluring, you know, the temptations of
wanting to be wanted, wanting to be
accepted. And I think there's also
statistics on, you know, single parent
households where, you know, if a mom is
religious or Christian and she doesn't
have her husband with her for whatever
reason and she has kids and they're
going to church, they're like less
likely to stay in church. whereas when
there's a a father in the picture,
they're more likely to be plugged into
the church. So, I think that is an
example of how important fathers are and
parents are period. Um, but yeah, I
think it comes down to attachment. I
think we can all have our own
perspective sharing our experiences of
that. Like my father, he was in the
military, so a lot of the time he was
gone. So there were periods where I was
I didn't have him there to build me up,
to affirm me, to show me what it means
to be a boy, what it means to be a young
man. And my mother and my younger sister
and my grandmother or my aunts, I have
only all girl cousins as well. So I I
was around a lot of femininity and a lot
of feminine energy. And the environment
I grew up in, I rejected that
masculinity because they were
sexualizing women. They were behaving in
a way that I thought was degrading to
the the women in my life that I felt I
needed to protect, I needed to be there
for. And so that's probably part of why
I was insecure about my masculinity. And
the times my father came home, he was,
you know, he had just got been deployed,
so he was going through his own mental
health needs. He would um escape through
video games. He would escape through
movies. And I would see him as very
serious, someone that I was a little
fearful of. I admired a part of him,
like him being hardworking and caring.
And my my dad did did hug and kiss me,
you know, like show affection to me, but
it's like I wasn't being poured in as
much. So, I think it just comes down to,
at least for me, that quality time with
your children and being vulnerable and
sharing your emotions. That sounds so
basic, but that goes a long ways to set
the tone that if they can trust their
parents, then that can also translate to
their relationship with God as their
creator. So that's just my thoughts.
Would you guys like to add or share for
your perspective? Yeah, I'll say for me,
um, I was like the young child and
because I guess I would be considered
more like the daddy's girl, but my dad,
he wouldn't be in the home because he
had left my mom, my sister, and I when I
was 3 years old. So, I was very young.
But even at that age, I remember a bit
where I'll be crying because I wanted my
dad. I wanted, you know, his hugs and,
you know, that attention from him, but I
was crying and I would ask my mom like,
"Where's Poppy? Like, where's dad?" And
he already had left. Um, so even at that
age, it's already creating this
longiness or this lack of attachment and
and not having that security of like my
dad is not here. And so growing up the
like you had mentioned Daniel of like it
wasn't enough where he would pick us up
over the weekend because they shared
custody. But every time he would drop me
off I would feel this sadness this
longingness in my heart of like why why
can my parents just be together? And
that's where eventually in my adulthood,
I found myself in a relationship with a
man like 7 years older than me because
he was more advanced and he kind of
reflected like that role of a father
like he was showing me things I didn't
know and filling me of words of
affirmation. Um, but I'll say like with
my dad, his love language would be
gifts, but mine's was quality time. So
because it was I wasn't receiving as how
I had wanted to. it would just be cut
like I appreciate the gifts but I'm like
like I want you I want to laugh with you
tickle me or just you know those moments
where it's like it doesn't have to be
something big just bonding together and
those things made made you vulnerable to
seeking out these alternatives and I
believe we you know we live in a
spiritual world so the devil came to
steal kill and destroy and he's after
humanity because he's lost his chance
for eternal salvation and he wants us to
lose that chance too. And I was
vulnerable too about um my family wasn't
really connected emotionally. We would
watch TV a lot. And I would remember
feeling like we're just so distracted
being entertained. And I would
communicate that to my mom and I would
say, "Ma, like I don't feel like we're
connected. I don't feel like we're
really like emotionally connected." And
she would recognize it and say, "Okay."
But I don't think she really understood
what was missing. you know, cuz they
were giving us, my sister and I, an
upbringing that was better than what how
they grew up, but um that emotional
intimacy was also the root of my need
growing up as well. That's amazing
because um I wrote an article a couple
of years ago. Um what impacted me is
that I talked to a lot of Christian
parents and you know, they stay married
and they have their kids, but these
parents are contentious. Like they don't
get along, but they're going to stay
married, you know, for the benefit of
their kids. And so the fathers are
bickering with the mothers and the
mothers are fighting with the fathers,
but they stay together. And what I
realized is that looking at my own
story, I had rejected my dad even before
I was conscious. So I remember when he
announced that they were getting a
divorce, I was glad. It was like good,
you're out of here. But I cannot deny
the fact that as a little kid, even
before I was 10 years old, like on a
Sunday morning when my mom would be
making breakfast and she'd be at the
stove and my sisters and I would be
sitting around the table and all of a
sudden my dad would just come out of
nowhere and he would just grab my mom
and fling her around and dip her back
and give her a kiss even while she was
holding the spatula in her hand, you
know, and then they would start dancing
in the kitchen. And I still know that at
that moment I knew that my world was
complete. It's not enough just to have
parents in the home. They need to be
connected for a child to feel safe, to
feel secure, to feel belonging and to
also feel that connection I believe and
that was really powerful to see that. So
you know just having both your parents
in the home is not enough. It's like
what is the relationship and what is the
environment of that home? I think makes
a huge difference. Amen. and we want to
be able to develop different programs
for a variety of people. So to go back
to coming together ministries a little
bit um you know I am the director of the
associate pathway program which means
there are associate speakers that have
experienced God's transformation in
their life. So because we're not just an
exgay ministry any longer. We have a
variety of speakers that have
experienced um sexual brokenness but
also sexual healing. We have one person
right now if you can talk about him a
little bit about him and his son. Right.
So it was his son that actually was
stalking our booth at at a youth event
that we had and his son I think was
about 15 years old and finally he had
the courage to come forward and talk
about how he had been sexually abused
and that awakened in him this samesex
attraction. And then you know because of
his age I knew that I needed to include
the the um the parents and so I said is
your mom or dad here? And I said, 'Well,
you know, bring your parent by. So, the
father came by and interestingly enough,
I had spoken to the father at another
youth rally a couple of years before
that. And as we were talking, um what
was really amazing is that the father
had also been abused as a young person.
And even though he wasn't gay, that
wasn't his um um attractions. You know,
it's interesting how the Bible talks
about the hereditary cycles. So here now
the father had that history and now his
son has that history and what's been
amazing is is now the father and the son
are wanting to get involved in ministry
and and we can think of so many
applications a men's ministry you know
youth ministries talking to young kids
about you know the dangers of of
promiscuity and sexual sin and all kinds
of stuff. So is that what you want me to
share? Yeah. So, an example that they're
they weren't LGBTQ, but they did
experience sexual issues. And it's
beautiful to see a father and a son be
able to to share that together and be
able to speak on that. And they are
interested in ministering through the
ministry and to give different programs
to churches, schools, conferences,
literally wherever God wants us to go.
We're here with LED Live. We praise God
for this opportunity to get the word out
there because Jesus is coming soon and
he wants us to be ready. And there's no
reason why we can't experience victory.
And that's we want everyone to
experience that. So Daniel, what I think
is is the most profound about that
father and son story is as a kid, if my
father would have made himself
vulnerable to me at all, like if in any
way I would have seen emotion or or
known that he was human in any way or
even to apologize or to make himself
vulnerable, that would have been a
connection. he would have been my hero
instead of this double-minded or, you
know, kind of two-faced Christian that
that I grew up with. And I think that's
so powerful. You know, like parents
don't want their kids to know that they
came from a past. And of course, there's
a limit to how much you should share.
But when a parent is vulnerable enough
to their child to let them know that
they know what struggle is like and and
how to find that victory and that
relationship with Jesus Christ, that
child automatically gets connected to
that parent. that child automatically
knows more of its value and its worth
and and and has that ability to be so
filled that when they're approached by
other things on the outside, you know, a
sexual situation, drugs, alcohol,
whatever the issue is, they're already
filled. And so that isn't a necessity
and they can say no to that thing. Amen.
I've always heard that you need to have
these conversations with your children
before their friends or someone else
does. And in today's world, it's getting
younger and younger and younger, right?
So to sort of beat him to the punch with
this beautiful gift that God has given
to us and and something that I if it is
experienced in the context that God has
designed it for is a beautiful thing. It
brings people closer together. It bonds
us together in a way that like no other
thing that we've been given can do. And
and the devil is just loving to get in
the middle of that. your sexuality is so
intertwined with your spirituality that
if the devil can mess up one of those,
he knows he messes up the other one. So,
I think that's why you see an all-right
attack on our sexuality is it's
literally going to mess up a lot of
people's spirituality. So, praise God
that you guys are taking the the the
bull by the horns and really getting out
there and and um you know, um we're
we're rooting you guys on. Thank you.
Thank you. So, if you guys are looking
at uh some of these topics and you want
to be blessed by this ministry, check
out Coming Together Ministries. Um you
guys have recently moved. You got a new
building. Where are you guys at? Yeah.
Yeah, we're actually in Southwest
Michigan and uh the building used to be
uh a law attorney on one side and a dog
groomer on the other side. And so, we've
remodeled it. We have our offices there
now. Uh Daniel and Kirsten came and
joined us and kicking and screaming
maybe a little bit, but um that's where
we're established right across the
street from a Christian university and
um yeah, it's it's been exciting in the
last year. Lots of changes. Would you
like to share how we were just visiting
other churches and God opened the
opportunity to use you as the Trojan
horse or as the opening wedge um to have
these sensitive conversations especially
in today's age? Yes. So God God knows
everything and he sees there's a need
and sometimes it's not being addressed.
So he just uses us in different ways
like kind of like the story of like
Philillip he just like okay go go to
this um individual that's seeking. So we
had that experience where um we were
going to church and they had lunch
afterwards and in the table that we were
gathered there were like three students
from that university there and I think
one was from Africa, another one from
England and then the other one was from
Canada. Mhm. And long story short, we
had shared uh our testimonies where you
know I shared where um you know growing
up and lack of a father figure that led
me to seeking romantic relationships and
that was my identity and I opened up
more in detail with them because I felt
like God was saying like say more like
they need to hear this and because they
were young women so I was um once in
their shoes not too long ago. Um, so I I
was transparent with them and basically
you could tell like in their countenance
like they were just like, "Wow." Like
they needed to hear what I had to share
with my testimony. But one in
particular, which was she was sitting on
my left. She you could tell like she
resonated either, you know, she had been
through some type of trauma, sexual
trauma, or she was in the same
predicament as I was. And so they had
mentioned that they don't hear this
transparency in the church like in um
Christian university even. Correct. like
the the most that they get is like, you
know, you can lose your salvation.
Um, and it's like on everyone's mind,
I'm sure, at that age. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
So, yeah. Well, you know what I find
really interesting is that Daniel and
Kirsten, they're energetic, they're
young, they have, you know, their whole
lives ahead of them. And so, you know,
they're checking out all these different
churches. And because you guys have a
Hispanic background and this topic is
not popular in in Hispanic culture, is
it? No. very taboo. You don't talk about
it at all. Right. So then once one uh
weekend they were actually visiting a
Spanish church in the area. Talk about
that a little bit if you would. Yes. Um
so we were visiting that church and um
this we were leaving and somebody
basically rec I don't know if she
recognized us but she said hello. She
greeted us and we got to talking and
shared a little bit about, you know, we
just moved to the area and she was
asking us questions and basically asked
what we did and because of how sensitive
it can be talking about um sexuality
amongst other Christians, we usually
just give a vague answer and if they ask
further questions then we'll go deeper.
So um that was like the green light to
continue to share further. and she
basically was saying, "Wow, we were just
talking about that ministry last week
with my sister and how people were
saying that this ministry is basically a
form of conversion therapy. So, we had a
chance to um clarify that we don't make
people straight. Um, we have had been an
exgay ministry and it's been rebranded
because we see that the need for sexual
integrity is is across the board for
everyone with a variety of preferences
and struggles. And so that was a chance
to spread the word and to be able to
market the ministry cuz not very many
people know about the rebrand, know
about our services. And we're still
developing a lot of the different
programs. So we're still early on, I
would say, um, with this stage in the
ministry. So that's a little bit about
that experience, right? And so to, you
know, because we are now in a location
across the street from a Christian
university, it's been great because now
we have a an annual conference that we
have. And part of the conference is to
minister to the church. And then we have
another program during that same week
for leadership to to educate pastors and
teachers and parents. And then we have
one that's really special to me and
that's what we call our CTL, which is
our coming together live event. And that
is actually for individuals that are
looking for victory, that are looking
for victory over many things. We even
have uh women talking about abortion
recovery, uh premarital sex, uh
pornography, addiction, um and and
that's really exciting because now we
have a location where we can do that
annually. So, our next event is coming
up and it's going to be from September
12th until the 20th and that'll be in
Berian Springs, Michigan. Yeah. So, it's
super cool. Awesome. You guys, this is a
um topic that I'm sure you could talk on
extensively for weeks and weeks on end.
I really mean it when I say this. I
praise God that there are ministries
like yours that exist out there that are
helping young people in this area. It is
not talked about enough. As you can see,
as you can see, you know, the
experiences that you've just bumped into
people and they appreciate your
openness, your honesty, and that's what
it really it takes. It takes an army of
people being honest with the situation
and then offering some help. And you
guys have a lot of cool resources.
Please check out their resources. Um if
you just go to comingto together
ministries.org. That's it. And uh you
can see a plethora of stuff. You guys
also have a YouTube page. Uhhuh. We do
lots of videos and Instagram. Yep. So
whatever your social media addiction is,
I'm sure you could find them there. and
uh they will be more than happy to reach
out to you guys. So, thank you guys for
being honest and coming on and sharing
with us. And um check these guys out.
And u if you know anybody that would
enjoy this episode, please share it with
them. Somebody that you know maybe just
has a a burden in their church to open
up the doors or talk about this kind of
a topic. Please feel free to look into
coming together ministries.org and uh
connect with these guys. Thank you for
showing showing up on the show. Thank
you to anytime.
If you like this video, like, subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos. And drop
a comment below and we'll try to get
back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. Oh, no. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]